[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und mitrisirin guten Abend Tag 157
des Ukraine Krieges je länger er tobt
desto schwieriger scheint es Einigkeit
und Mitgefühl aufrecht zu erhalten Werte
und Emotionen die auch wichtig sind um
Moskaus kaltem Kalkül etwas
entgegenzusetzen währenddessen droht
Ländern Afrikas des Nahen Ostens und
Asiens eine Hungerkatastrophe
verzweifelt warten sie darauf dass
endlich Schiffe mit Millionen Tonnen
Getreide die ukrainischen Häfen
verlassen
die Lage bleibt dennoch unübersichtlich
genauso wie das brutale Kriegsgeschehen
für den Angriff auf das Gefängnis in der
Region Donezk mit dutzenden Toten machen
sich Russland und die Ukraine
gegenseitig verantwortlich Kamran
safiarian berichtet
Kämpfer ihr Helden der Ukraine schreien
sie heute in Kiew Angehörige der
ukrainischen Soldaten in russischer
Kriegsgefangenschaft im Gefängnis von
olielevka viele hier wissen nicht ob
Ihre Liebsten noch am Leben sind
mein Sohn ist in Gefangenschaft er war
dort ich weiß nicht wie es ihm geht wo
er ist aber noch am Leben ist es ist der
blanke Horror
sie haben unsere Kinder ermordet das
sind doch Kinder sie trifft keine Schuld
sie haben nur ihre Heimat verteidigt
über 50 Tote forderte der gestrige
Angriff auf das Gefängnis wir machen die
verbrannten Leichen unkenntlich der
ukrainische Geheimdienst beschuldigt
Russland damit gezielt Verbrechen an
Ukrainern vertuscht haben zu wollen
es war eine vorsätzliches russisches
Kriegsverbrechen an vorsätzlicher
Massenmord ukrainischer Kriegsgefangener
Russland sollte als staatlicher
Unterstützer des Terrorismus eingestuft
werden
nicht Russland die Ukraine selbst habe
das Gefängnis beschossen so die Version
der Separatisten
ausgepackt hatten die von Kiew
angeordnet waren entschied die Regierung
Ukraine den Beschluss des Lagers mit
einem amerikanischen
mehrfachraketenwerfer
wer wirklich hinter dem Angriff steckt
konnte bisher nicht unabhängig überprüft
werden dem Roten Kreuz ist der Zugang
zum Gefängnis bisher verwehrt worden die
Kämpfe indes gehen weiter in harkev
wurde heute eine Schule zerstört
ukrainische Weizenfelder in Brand
gesteckt
Erntezeit da feiern Sie ganz bewusst auf
uns und unsere Ausrüstung
die Ernte steckt seit Tagen im
Schwarzmeerhafen von Odessa fest mehrere
Millionen tonnengetreide auf voll
beladenen Frachtern stehen bereit wann
sie ablegen ist weiterhin unklar
Anne Brühl ist für uns in Odessa eine
alle wollen wissen warum die Schiffe
nicht ablegen warum geht es nicht los
und wann könnte es soweit sein
ja eine Frage die sich viele hier
stellen die Ukraine betont ja immer
wieder wir sind bereit von uns aus kann
es sofort losgehen 17 Schiffe liegen
voll beladen in den Häfen rund um Odessa
man wartet hier auf grünes Licht der
Vereinten Nationen und der Türkei die
für sicherheitskorridore garantieren
sollen wir hören auch dass es
möglicherweise Diskussionen um
verschiedene Routen gibt das könnte das
Ganze verzögern vor der Hafeneinfahrt
von Odessa haben sich heute offenbar
russische Kriegsschiffe zurückgezogen ob
das ein gutes Zeichen ist das muss man
allerdings mal abwarten denn die Lage
hier in Odessa ist sehr angespannt die
Russen hatten ja immer wieder Raketen
auf den Hafen aber auch auf die Stadt
abgeschossen und das nachdem sie das
getreideabkommen unterzeichnet hatten
für großes Vertrauen hat das hier also
nicht gesorgt im Gegenteil die Stadt ist
voller Checkpoints die Soldaten das
haben wir heute auch selbst erlebt sind
sehr nervös man wird sehr genau
kontrolliert vor allen Dingen entlang
der Küstenlinie und die Sorge ist eben
die dass die Russen die Zeit nutzen
könnten um Fakten zu schaffen
militärische Fakten angespannte
Situationen in Odessa danke Anne für
deine Schilderung über das was in der
Ukraine geschieht wird hierzulande
inzwischen anders gesprochen die
Auswirkungen für uns stehen häufig im
Vordergrund es wird gestritten über
Waffenlieferungen gasengpässe über
höhere Preise und wie sie abgefedert
werden können für Hunderttausende
ukrainische geflüchtete die jetzt in
Deutschland leben sicherlich schwer
nachvollziehbar sie verloren ihr Zuhause
einige blickten in menschliche Abgründe
wurden auf der Flucht vergewaltigt
betrauern getötete Partner und Kinder
Wunden die wahrscheinlich vielfach nicht
verheilen werden aber behandelt werden
können wie zum Beispiel in einer
speziellen Berliner Einrichtung die uns
Stefanie Hein näher bringt
Begrüßung auf Ukrainisch in einer
Berliner psychiatriesprechstunde Xenia
poljakova ist aus Kiew geflohen ihr Mann
ist an der Front
immer gesund sagt sie doch seit dem
Krieg nur noch ein Nervenbündel von
Albträumen geplagt
ich höre immer zu hier den Notarzt oder
die Polizei und die Sirenen die sind so
gleich wie der Luftalarm in Kiew wie
immer wieder Alarm das ist es was mich
um den Schlaf bringt
dr Irina Gottes selbst in Kiew geboren
arbeitet seit Jahren in Berlin jetzt ist
sie für ukrainische geflüchtete da hört
oft Geschichten die sich ähneln die
benennen ist wie Syndrom das
Überlebenden wo man Sorge hat um
angehören zum einen aber auch schlechtes
Gewissen hat dass man überhaupt lebt und
darüber sprechen wir das ist auch
wichtig ist als ob psychochhygiene
wichtig ist trotzdem gesund zu bleiben
vielsprachiges Murmeln in der
Teamsitzung am Zentrum für
transkulturelle Psychiatrie beim
Berliner Vivantes humboldt-klinikum
medizinische psychologische pflegerische
und sozialarbeiterische Kompetenz sitzt
hier mit Chef Prof Breunig am Tisch und
immer geht es auch um Social
media-kommentare zum Weltgeschehen denn
das treibt ihre Patienten um es kommen
auch viele Bilder die mit Tod und
Verzweiflung verbunden sind
professor Peter Bräunig hat das Zentrum
2006 in Berlin eröffnet im
Einwanderungsland Kanada hat er gesehen
wie es funktioniert zunächst für
Russlanddeutsche hat der heute
muttersprachliche Teams für die
hauptherkunftsregionen von Flüchtlingen
aufgebaut jetzt auch für Menschen aus
der Ukraine die brauchen eine Beratung
man muss sich darum kümmern was da in
der Heimat schon behandelt worden ist
wie die Anamnesen sind wie
Krankengeschichten sind und wir brauchen
eine anständige Diagnostik als Grundlage
der Therapie wir müssen sehen
welche pharmakotherapien bisher gelaufen
sind und welche sinnvoll weiter
erforderlich sind und das können wir auf
dem Weg bringen Hilfe suchende kommen
mit Überweisungen oder direkt vom
Erstaufnahmezentrum Xenia Polyakova hat
über Verwandte von der Sprechstunde
erfahren für sie ein großes Glück
es ist viel einfacher über so private
Dinge in deiner eigenen Sprache zu
sprechen und du glaubst dem Arzt auch
mehr du vertraust ihm
Xenia poljakova hätte nie gedacht dass
sie mal die Hilfe der Psychiatrie
braucht aber das sagt sie noch es hat
ihr so geholfen
und jetzt haben wir weitere wichtige
Nachrichten und da bleiben wir in der
Ukraine
über die Situation der Sinti und Roma in
der Ukraine informiert sich nahe Kiew
Mehmet Daimer Güler der Beauftragte der
Bundesregierung gegen Antiziganismus
heute besuchte er die Gedenkstätte
babinja dort wird der von deutschen
Nationalsozialisten 1941 erschossenen
Juden gedacht die Massenerschießung von
mehr als 33.000 Juden war das größte
einzelmassaker im Zweiten Weltkrieg auf
europäischen Boden auch tausende Sinti
und Roma wurden dort ermordet
bundesaußenministerin baerbock hat zum
Abschluss ihres türkei-besuchs Vertreter
der Zivilgesellschaft und der Opposition
getroffen diese reagierten positiv auf
die klaren Worte bärbox an den
türkischen Außenminister chavuolo von
dem sie unter anderem die Freilassung
des Oppositionellen Kavala gefordert
hatte beerburg würdigte den
zivilgesellschaftlichen Austausch als
das Herz des Miteinanders in den
deutsch-türkischen Beziehungen
im Irak haben tausende Anhänger des
schiitischen Geistlichen mugtaler
al-sadre das Parlament gestürmt zum
zweiten Mal innerhalb weniger Tage die
Demonstranten wollen verhindern dass
politische Gegner der als sadre Bewegung
eine Regierung bilden seit den Wahlen im
letzten Herbst dauert der Machtkampf an
immer wieder kommt es zu Protesten und
Ausschreitungen
Papst franziskus hat nach seiner
Kanada-Reise den Umgang mit indigenen
Kindern in katholischen Internaten
erstmals als eine Form von Völkermord
bezeichnet mehrfach hatte franziskus die
indigenen um Vergebung gebeten bis 1996
hatte die kanadische Regierung etwa
150.000 indigene Kinder in kirchlich
geführte Internate geschickt viele waren
dort misshandelt worden tausende
gestorben auf dem Rückflug schloss der
85-Jährige zudem einen Amtsverzicht
nicht aus wegen seiner Kniebeschwerden
wolle er nicht mehr so oft reisen
Musik kann einen durch die Zeit biemen
aktuell tut das running up that hill der
1985er Hit von Kate Bush damals siegte
Boris Becker als jüngster Spieler in
Wimbledon der erste Teil von zurück in
die Zukunft lief im Kino und
1985 wurde außerdem die gesunkene
Titanic entdeckt ich erzähle ihnen dass
alles weil running up that hill gerade
wieder die Charts erobert hatte was an
einer Serie liegt die den Song benutzt
hat und das begeistert übrigens auch
jüngere wie bestimmt auch das heute
ziemlich farbgewaltig einem anderen Song
von Kate Bush geholtigt wurde und wie
genau das zeigt uns jetzt Sebastian
Gorski
möglichst viele Menschen in roten
Kleidern
gepaart mit modernem Ausdruckstanz und
der mystischen Musik von Kate Bush
das ist eine Kombination die Samantha
wearing seit 2016 zum alljährlichen
happening gemacht hat
inspiriert wurde sie vom damals schon
geheimnisvollen Musikvideo zum cooltipp
Wuthering Heights aus dem Jahr 1978
[Musik]
sie sehen eine Freude auf die Geschichte
das dass wir alles
Agenda aller aller alte zusammenkommen
und zusammen tanzen ein bisschen Freude
mitnehmen das ist alles
mittlerweile finden solche knallroten
Tanzperformances in über 40 Städten
weltweit statt ein absolutes Revival der
Sängerin Kate Bush
auslöser dafür war aber ein anderes Lied
von ihr running up that hill das durch
die netflix-serie stranger things 37
Jahre nach Veröffentlichung weltweit die
Charts stürmt und damit auch ein
jüngeres Publikum erreicht
ich fühle mich immer so flattrig wenn
ich das höre und hat irgendwie so eine
gewisse Magie und ist halt einfach gute
Songs viele Leute sagen die Kinder haben
Kate Bush gefunden es war gut gut sie
müssen das sehen sie ist ein Vorbild für
uns alles ist Künstlerinnen als als
Frauen als Leute wie wir durch den Wald
gehen sollen denn Kate Bush stand schon
immer selbstbewusst für das anders sein
abseits vom musikalischen Mainstream
eine schraulichkeit Exzentrik und
Weiblichkeit die damals wie heute ein
buntes Publikum ansieht in einer BBC
Radiosendung auf den erneuten Erfolg
angesprochen zeigt sich die mittlerweile
64-Jährige Kate Bush selbst überrascht
wirklich wundervoll ist dass meine Songs
jetzt von einem ganz neuen Publikum
gehört werden in vielen Fällen haben sie
vorher noch nie von mir gehört dass
liebe ich einfach die Vorstellung dass
diese jungen Menschen meine Musik jetzt
erst entdecken ist wirklich besonders
und im besten Sinne verrückt ist dieser
Hype um Kate Bush der offensichtlich
auch Glückshormone freisetzt
und noch einmal Nachrichten keine
Entspannung der Lage haben Regenfälle
bei den Waldbränden in der Sächsischen
Schweiz gebracht die kurze Niederschläge
verursachten nur Rauch aus glutnästern
ohne eine Änderung der Wetterlage sehen
die Behörden in Sachsen keine Chance die
Feuer unter Kontrolle zu bekommen
betroffen sind etwa 150 Hektar Wald
und das Wetter bleibt auch in Sachsen
trocken mit etwas Regen ist nur im
Nordwesten zu rechnen dort bringt ein
kleines Tief dichte Wolken und
vereinzelt Gewitter sonst Mischung aus
Sonne und Wolken und eben trocken 21
Grad an der Nordsee bis 32 Grad am
Oberrhein am Montag wechselhaft bei 21
bis 31 Grad Dienstag im Nordwesten etwas
Regen Mittwoch wieder sehr sonnig und
heiß
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto
ohne Gewähr
8-19 25 27 33 34 Superzahl 6 mehr auf
Lotto zdf.de und im zdf-text
so das ZDF-Sportstudio mit Sven Voß
wartet auf Sie unter anderem mit dem
DFB-Pokal und einer Einstimmung auf das
morgige Fußball-EM Finale England
Deutschland und direkt danach gibt es
hier wieder eine heute Express und ja
wir sehen uns morgen wieder tschüss von
uns schönen Abend
[Musik]